gun laws in Nevada have fewer
restrictions in other states and Don
Dahler is here with a look at what can
be purchased Don good morning good
morning as Nevada is viewed as having
some of the most lacks gun control laws
in the country you can openly carry a
gun without a permit gun registration is
not required and there is no mandated
waiting period for firearm purchases as
with most states is gonna surprise a lot
of people it is also legal to own what's
called a class three weapon which
includes fully automatic machine guns
short-barreled shotguns and weapons with
silencers investigators found some of
these weapons in the suspects possession
only law enforcement and military
personnel can have new versions of these
sort of weapons but civilians can
purchase fully automatic weapons if they
are manufactured prior to May of 1986
the old versions can cost anywhere
between fifteen and fifty thousand
dollars but you can modify newer and
cheaper semi-automatic weapons to be
fully automatic for as little as $50
police believe the suspect in las vegas
modified some of his weapons to be fully
automatic to legally obtain a class
three weapon you have to pass a federal
background check file an application
with local law enforcement and pay a two
hundred dollar fee Nevada does not have
a limits on bulk sales of ammunition or
magazine capacity meaning one can fire
for a longer period of time without
having to reload we asked the NRA about
some of Nevada's gun laws and if they
had a comment about the number of
weapons that shooter had they have not
responded it will be interesting and so
far no response as you point out many
people thought after Newtown with the
slaughter really little children in
their classrooms that gun laws would
change I don't know if this will make
any difference that is a very gun
friendly state it's a very gun friendly
in fact not far from where Nora is there
is an indoor shooting range where they
can shoot fully automatic weapons for
fun just for fun Thank You Don Dahler